Pour ce sujet, j'ai décidé de me faire tatouer
le visage de ce doux ange
Putain, mais c'est quoi ça ?
[Rire de Cyril Hanouna]
Ca partira jamais ? Si ça s'enlève
Après ma vidéo sur le tatouage, je vous avais donné rendez-vous dans deux mois
pour le détatouage
Et bien voilà, c'est aujourd'hui
Le moment est venu
C'est pas juste aujourd'hui en fait
Mais je vais vous expliquer ça après
Pour me le faire retirer, j'avais plusieurs options
La chirurgie par exemple
Mais bon, pour un tatouage aussi gros, ça faisait quand même beaucoup de peau à enlever
Il y a aussi une pommade commercialisée depuis peu qui promet monts et merveilles
mais bon, on va attendre un petit peu avec ce genre de produits
histoire d'avoir un peu de recul
Non, moi j'ai choisi de taper dans le
grand classique :
Le LASER
Mais commençons par le début, avant même la première séance
il y a un rendez-vous avec le médecin
Aujourd'hui, c'est un jour important parce que j'ai rendez-vous au centre de LASER
pour caler tous les détails de mon détatouage
Normalement, c'est OK hein, mais j'ai quand même la petite appréhension que le médecin
jette un œil à mon tatouage et me dise
"Ah ben non mon vieux, ça je vais pas pouvoir vous le retirer, vous me garder ça"
C'est une consultation assez classique au cours de laquelle le médecin s'assure
que vous ne prenez pas des médicaments photosensibilisants
c'est-à-dire, qui entraîne une réaction en cas d'exposition au soleil
mais aussi en cas d'exposition aux lasers
Il se renseigne aussi sur vos antécédents, maladies et allergies éventuelles
par exemple, si vous êtes enceinte, le médecin préférera appliquer le principe de précaution
Et refusera de vous détatouer
Ensuite, si le tatouage est situé dans une zone où la peau est bronzée
Il faudra attendre un peu, parce que le laser peut laisser des traces blanches dans ces cas là
Et c'est pas ce qu'on veut
Bien sûr les machines ont des réglages adaptés aux peaux mates ou aux peaux noires
Le médecin en profite pour inspecter le tatouage
pour vous dire que dans mon cas, il a été un peu surpris
ce qui lui permet d'assurer que la peau est saine
et aussi, d'évaluer le nombre de séances à prévoir
Tout ça dépend du type et de la couleur de l'encre
mais aussi de sa quantité et de la profondeur des traits
En ce qui me concerne, on est parti pour 6 séances
Et vu que vous vous posez la question et que c'est effectivement une information qui a son importance
C'est 150 euros la séance
Mais selon, le type de laser, le centre, le médecin et le site de tatouage
ça peut aller de 3 à 15 séances, voire plus
pour 80 à 300 euros à chaque fois, voire plus
et oui, ça double pique
Ok, mais comment ça marche ?
Et ben suivez-moi, je vais vous montrer ça tout de suite enfin, aller !
Alors...
Ben, non... euh, non ! Pas du tout
[Bruit de tir et cri de Chewbacca]
Mais non, enfin...
Mais non..
En réalité, il existe plusieurs type de lasers
En l’occurrence, là, c'est un Q switched
Le laser, c'est rien d'autre que de la lumière qui est amplifiée
et émise sous la forme d'un faisceau composé de photons
c'est-à-dire de particules qui composent la lumière
Il y plusieurs particularités
Le laser est unidirectionel
C'est-à-dire que le faisceau est très précis ce qui lui permet de se concentrer sur un point
Il est monochromatique, c'est-à-dire que ses rayonnements ont tous la même longueur d'onde ou à peu près
Avec le Q switched, on peut sélectionner différentes longueurs d'onde
qui sont efficaces chacune sur des couleurs précises
Sachez par exemple que le jaune, le vert, et le bleu turquoise sont des couleurs qui sont difficiles à faire partir
mais que le noir, ça va
Juste, méfiance, parfois les encres sont mélangées pour obtenir une couleur
Et du coup, l'une peut partir mais pas l'autre
Vous auriez l'air malin avec un tatouage tout jaune, hein ?
Alors par précaution avant de commencer, on se protège les yeux
Vous allez voir, ça donne un swag assez indéfinissable
Donc là ce qu'il se passe, c'est que la machine projette des photons sur mon fessare
Une très grande quantité d'énergie
sur un temps très court, de l'ordre de la nanoseconde
Alors, vous vous en doutez, une aussi grande quantité d'énergie
même sur une nanoseconde, ça pique
En gros, les zones qui sont douloureuses à tatouer sont aussi douloureuses à détatouer, mais en pire
"Ca va mon grand ?" "J'en chie"
"Ah ouais ça pique" "Je peux vraiment le dire : j'en chie"
On peux mettre une pommade anesthésiante une à deux heures avant le rendez-vous mais il y a
des gens chez qui il faut baisser l'intensité donc l'efficacité du laser
Il y en a même qui sont obligés d'arrêter avant la fin du traitement
C'est quand même ballot
Wouaw
Aller, tiens bon mon grand, aller !
Ah oui, ça pique, oui
Papa regarde
L'énergie envoyée par le laser fait exploser l'encre en de multiples petites particules
Et c'est là qu'interviennent des cellules dont on avait déjà parler dans la vidéo sur le tatouage
"En plus, les cellules qui sont chargées de faire le ménage dans le derme, qu'on appelle des macrophages
Elles n'arrivent pas à évacuer les pigments de l'encre, parce qu'ils sont trop fat pour elles"
Et ben voilà, une fois l'encre explosée, ces fameux macrophages peuvent faire leur job : le ménage
Alors, comme ça, on a l'impression que c'est bon, tout est parti
Mais en fait pas du tout, cet aspect blanchâtre qu'on voit à la surface
c'est juste du gaz qui est libéré sur le passage du laser
mais dans quelques heures, le motif
original va refaire surface
Attendez, il refait quand même vachement surface là non ?
Il parait que c'est normal, parce que même si ces foutriquets de macrophages sont des sacrés petits boulus
et bah, ils mangent pas tout d'un coup
C'est pour cela qu'il faut y retourner
mais qu'il faut attendre deux mois, le temps qu'ils digèrent
Après la séance, il suffit de respecter les consignes du médecin
et de refaire son pansement avec de la pommade cicatrisante, comme il vous le prescrit
Le moment du pansement, c'est assez clairement le meilleur moment
Et il ne faut pas exposer la zone au soleil pendant 2 mois
Il y a des traces brunes plus ou moins persistantes qui pourraient apparaitre
Donc pour résumer, se faire retirer un tatouage, c'est beaucoup plus long
et beaucoup plus douloureux que se faire tatouer
C'est aussi beaucoup plus cher et le résultat n'est pas garanti à 100%
Alors évidemment c'est pas moi qui vais vous faire la morale, ni vous dire ce que vous avez à faire
mais au moins maintenant, vous avez les cartes en main pour décider
Ensuite, vous avez compris je suis parti pour un an de traitements
Donc, il va falloir attendre un peu pour juger de l'efficacité du traitement
Parce que oui, il y a toujours le risque que tout ne parte pas complètement
Et je ne vous cache pas que je ne suis pas tranquille
Bon, au pire, on peux recouvrir les traces avec un nouveau tatouage
Promis, je vous monterai régulièrement l'évolution
du chantier
En attendant, on se retrouve très bientôt pour de nouvelles vidéos
D'ici là, comme d'habitude, mettez-vous bien, et puis également, portez-vous bien